You know what,
it has been a tough week.
There's a lot of anger
and shouting recently,
some of it within the-the last
30 seconds, to be honest.
So I felt that this would be
a great time for a segment
that highlights
some feel-good stories
about the real people out
in real America.
It's a brilliant idea
that I just had
and small-town stations have
been stealing from me for years.
It's time to take a look at some
of the week's best videos
in our segment called
Hey, Watch This.
We get to meet some more
of Eric's Heroes.
REPORTER: It's time for
Cool People Doing Cool Things.
REPORTER 2:
7 Everyday Heroes.
For Goodness' Sake,
I'm Bill Anderson.
(chuckles):
Oh.
For goodness' sake,
I'm Jordan Klepper.
And unlike local news,
I can afford lamp shades.
You know what,
let's take the focus off of me
and put it on the everyman
doing good
in my long-running,
first-time segment,
Jordan's Heroes.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering and applause)
Um, first up,
a man who loves
the great outdoors
almost as much as he loves
helping those in need.
Which is a lot,
if that wasn't clear.
A man is traveling across
the country to spread goodwill,
and his only tool
is a lawn mower.
Rodney Smith Jr.'s known
as Lawnmower Man.
He says the idea came
from a chance encounter
he had one day
with an elderly man.
He looked like he was
struggling, so I pulled over
and helped him out.
That night, I decided
to mow free lawns
for the elderly,
disabled, single mothers,
and veterans.
McBROOM: Smith says
he'll travel to all 50 states
to mow laws for those in need.
Wow, inspiring story,
mowing lawns for the needy
in all 50 states.
Your neighbors must love you.
Heck, the whole country
is gonna be your neighbor soon.
Everyone's friend,
that's you, Rodney.
Everybody loves Rodney.
Rodney, must feel pretty good
about yourself.
Pretty... good.
Hey, Rodney...
You think you're better than me?
Is that what you think, Rodney?
I can mow lawns
in all 50 states.
I'm handy, I'm good with tools.
I built a birdhouse
in fifth grade,
a good one,
the bird is still in it.
I can buy a lawn mower.
I can definitely buy one,
and find one,
and identify one
in a hardware store,
then I can buy it
in a heartbeat.
How much could it be?
I don't know.
$30,000, probably, could be.
Plus, I can go to any state
I want,
as long as it's not both Dakotas
or one of the Virginias.
They know what they did.
Screw you, Rodney.
You're not better than me.
This next story is sure
to make you smile.
And maybe also a bit hungry.
A fast food worker in
Chesterfield County
is receiving a lot of praise
after this video went viral.
You can see him--
Run, Forrest, run--
chasing down a customer who
forgot part of her order.
The dedicated worker
successfully got
the customer's second bag
of food to her
before jogging back and looking
just a little bit tired.
Oh, well,
you can't argue with that.
That's just a nice thing to do.
Glad a nice guy like that
in the middle of the country
is getting that kind
of attention.
He's probably feeling pretty
good about--
You think you're better than me?
That's not a run,
that's a shuffle at best.
I've sprinted out
of Chick-fil-As
twice as fast as that,
carrying way more bags
of morally-dubious
fried chicken.
And how dare you abandon
your post?
It's chaos back at that
Chick-fil-A with you gone.
They're serving burritos
and grilling pad Thai,
and not weighing in on what
constitutes love anymore.
You're a monster.
How on Earth can you think
you're better than me?
Up next...
Have you got a heart ticking in
your chest?
Careful, this story
is sure to melt it.
Superdaddy saved the big show.
Take a look.
Little Bella, hysterical,
crying on stage during her
annual ballet recital.
Dad appears from the wings
to try to calm her down.
MALE TV REPORTER:
Ah, with the baby.
FEMALE TV REPORTER:
While holding a baby,
-Yeah.
-he joined the ballet line.
Look at the plié.
He's like,
"I got this. I'm Superdad."
(bleep) you, Superdad!
You think you're better than me?
You think you're such
a great dad
because your amazing moment
of superdad-ness went viral
and your kids will love you
forever and ever?
You think I can't go viral?
You think I can't dance
with a baby?
Someone give me a baby.
Yes. There we go.
(cheering and applause)
And give me some music.
Some real Super Ballet-Dad shit.
-(sweet music plays)
-Ah, yeah. See?
You are not better than me.
Shove this up
your Facebook feed.
You know what? Puppy me.
(bleep) it.
Yeah. Oh.
(cheering and applause)
Did you have a dog? Yeah?
Who's your Superdad now, bitch?
As a matter of fact,
bring on the summer interns.
Ah, yeah. See, this is easy.
I could do this all day.
Dance with me, kids,
dance with me.
Dance with me.
My kids love me, too.
No one's better than me.
I'm the Superdad.